see the looks on some Democrats faces
today after the government was reopened
was thoroughly entertaining I was
smiling all day long
DYFS I look like she ate something bad
in the Senate dining room and disturbin
Durbin looked like he swallowed bob
corker look at him Donald Trump in the
Republican leadership outsmarted them
again was again it's Wiley coyote in the
Roadrunner the idiotic move by Chuck
Schumer to shut down the government to
help illegal immigrants was wildly
unpopular and he quickly felt the
white-hot heat from the public even by
Friday more Americans understood the
truth that liberals in Washington put
the interests of daca people ahead of
the well-being of our men and women in
the armed forces now think about it this
way
imagine being deployed in Afghanistan
maybe you're on your multiple
deployments you're away from your family
for several months and then you find out
that the fools on the hill are more
worried about illegal aliens than about
you and your family that must feel
really good it's disgraceful all it took
was McConnell promising to work on the
immigration issue until February 8th and
if nothing was resolved by then to have
a free and open debate on immigration
including a doc affects it ends the
shutdown and restores full funding for
the federal government through February
the 8th if an agreement isn't reached by
February the 8th the Senate will
immediately proceed to consideration of
legislation dealing with daca ooh big
win Chuck the Boston Globe's Matt Weiser
summed it up this way in a tweet he said
Democrats have managed to accede to
Republican demands demoralized they're
energized base give a disengaged
president a win and looked like they
held a meaningless three-day government
shutdown all at once I couldn't have
summed it up better myself in before the
shutdown the Democrats a dream of taking
back power it was already slowly slowly
fading away because of the roaring stock
market and the strength of the overall
economy
so now what do our left-wing friends
across politics in the media do to save
face just a fool like he's just an idiot
like he's a stupid old blubbery man who
doesn't know what he's doing the
president was not involved these past
few days
despite that they've reached this
compromise the president doesn't have a
good sense of his governing style this
is the second time his staff has
basically had to trick him into watching
TV and tweeting instead of being
hands-on after he bungled it by being
hands-on I'm watching Nicole Wallace and
I keep thinking it's Mika Brzezinski I
can't they're all becoming one person
now when I'm watching them now it's
amazing how many of the same fanatics by
the way have been trying to ram through
amnesty since 2006 think of them it's
Graham Schumer and Durbin all back the
three amigos now the president has got
to be very careful and in the coming
days and weeks not to allow the foxes
into the henhouse as the debate moves
forward you think about it Republicans
could not rid us of Obamacare last year
after all those votes that they had when
it didn't matter but now by golly
they're obsessed with helping illegal
immigrants and they're gonna get it done
as for Democrats they just want to
repeal and replace those blue-collar
Americans who voted for Trump with new
immigrants who vote for Democrats the
president has got to hold firm and I
think you will know chain migration know
Visa Lottery real funding for the wall
not just authorization but
appropriations and then I guess maybe do
the doctor thing you have all the
leverage don't give it to the
politicians mr. president who don't
respect you or your supporters and by
the way there's some more evidence that
Trump is more in the mainstream on
immigration than Lindsey or Chuck will
ever be check out this new Harvard
Harris poll that just came out it tells
a really good tale 65% versus 35%
support a daca deal that ends chain
migration eliminates the Visa Lottery
and secures the border with a wall 60
eight percent of respondents oppose the
visa lottery
eighty-one percent want to see legal
immigration level slash you heard it
slashed seventy nine percent think
immigration should be based on skills
rather than family ties and sixty
percent believe dreamers should not be
given preference to bring their
relatives to the United States sixty-one
percent think current border security is
inadequate fifty-four percent support a
physical barrier along the southern
border and a whopping seventy nine
percent wants secure borders rather than
open borders well facts never got in the
way of these open borders Republicans
before but maybe we can hope that
Lindsey Graham Jeff Flake and the others
get the message meanwhile we stay on the
corruption wash as we learned today that
the FBI somehow managed to lose five
months worth of texts huh
and I was shocked shocked I tell you to
have found out that the only text the
FBI failed to preserve were messages
between that anti-trump FBI investigator
Peter struck and his paramour FBI
attorney Lisa page now remember both
worked on the Muller and Clinton email
investigations huh and it was during
that key period between December 2016
through May 2017 that the bureau claims
a technical problem with updating
software caused the failure to preserve
these messages so are you saying that
it's just like when we get stuff on our
iPhone and you want the update and we
always say no because we don't want the
phone to slow down is that what happened
this is ridiculous the FBI if you
believe their explanation here I have a
pet rock I want to sell you by the way I
loved my pet rock when it came out
Attorney General Jeff Sessions has got
to step in now I ever recused himself
and that was frankly not necessary from
the FBI Russia investigation but now
we need an independent review of all of
this monkey business there's too much to
explain away by the way we have a lot
more on that coming up you do not want
to move because it's hot tonight the
show is hot including by the way the
gradual push to release the house Intel
memo and the the FBI warrant abuse that
we've been talking about for days on the
show there's new news on that but there
is other huge economic news today that
I've got to get to that's going to be
overlooked by everybody in the media but
not here once again will show that
President Trump is fulfilling the
promises that he made we will stand up
to trade cheating cheating cheaters
that's what they are cheaters we will
stand up to trade cheating anywhere and
everywhere it threatens the American job
the u.s. trade reps office just
announced that it will grant relief in
the form of major tariffs against
imported solar cells and modules as well
as large residential washing machines
Trump Trade Chief Bob light Heiser cited
section 201 in the Trade Act of 1974 a
law that gives the president
discretionary authority to grant relief
if the International Trade Commission
finds that imports have been a
substantial cause of serious injury it's
a real finding here there had been a
pattern of unfair trade practices going
on for years and this is the first time
this law provided any relief since the
early 2000s it's great news now can you
imagine Obama ever doing this or frankly
Hillary Clinton well Hillary Clinton
would have never done it because it was
her husband back in 2000 who thought it
was such a great idea for China to join
the WTO remember Obama did use tariffs
once on tires but that was only directed
at China Trump's tariffs apply to a
large number of countries engaged in
this abuse
now of course today's trade enforcement
action was greeted by the usual
globalist hair on fire reporting it's
all wrong
but it's so predictable again this
pattern
unfair trade practices in major
industries and this is just the
beginning is obscene and oftentimes even
we when we go to the World Trade
Organization World Trade Court and they
judge in our favor the offending
countries do not rectify the damage and
the damage to American companies is
already done by the time they get any
relief well I'll tell you this I'm trade
on immigration so many issues there is
truly a new sheriff in town and we're
putting American industry first American
workers first the American people first
and it's about time and that's the angle